seguimos aquí rodrigo en esta sede del
pacto histórico acaba de haber
celebración tras escuchar resultados
tanto de la consulta interpartidista
como los del congreso tanto del senado
como de la cámara de representantes- y
tenemos aquí con nosotros a laura
bocanegra que es la coordinadora
nacional de la candidatura de gustavo
petro y que le quería preguntar si está
siendo una noche feliz
[Música]
bueno
coordinadora del voluntariado pero para
aclararlo no estamos muy emocionados y
emocionados precisamente estamos
verificando que en este momento pasto
histórico es la primera fuerza hasta
ahora con el 24 por ciento de mesas
contadas pero es una noticia muy
importante que no se empieza a
posicionar como una fuerza relevante en
la constitución de este nuevo congreso
entonces si sentimos bastante emoción
también sabemos que la gente en las
calles está muy motivada que salieron a
votar masivamente como quizás nunca
antes en la historia de este país
veíamos los puestos de votación pues muy
concurridos entonces estamos muy muy
felices también por
estabas comenta antes de rodrigo todo el
fenómeno juvenil que ha habido en
colombia sobre todo con las protestas
del pasado año el 28 de abril que fueron
las más grandes en décadas donde hubo
decenas de muertos también denuncias de
abusos a los derechos humanos por parte
de la violencia policial y quería
preguntarte laura si estos resultados
que estamos viendo estas tendencias del
pacto histórico también tienen relación
con aquel descontento social estamos
absolutamente convencidos que el
estallido social propiciado el año
pasado demuestra una transformación un
cambio de mentalidad y la necesidad de
transformación y exigencia de derechos
de la ciudadanía sobre todo de la
ciudadanía juvenil entonces creemos
absolutamente que el reflejo de estas
votaciones
es el reflejo de ese anhelo de la gente
que salió a las calles a buscar en
transformar ya exigir sus derechos
entonces también nos sentimos muy
contentos y contentos porque incluso
estas listas lo que pretendieron también
fue incluir un poco esa
[Música]
estas voces esas voces que quizás si no
hubiera sido este estallido
no hubieran sido o no hubieran estado
recogidas en estas listas o en la
intención de este este pacto histórico
entonces muy muy contentos también de
haber logrado
y los jóvenes como estáis viendo porque
yo estaba mirando mi timeline en twitter
y lo que más veo aparte de la victoria
de petró también es el fenómeno de
francia market que está sacando un gran
número de devotos como lo ven desde el
voluntariado la próxima vicepresidenta
bueno candidata a la vicepresidencia con
gestión si sean hombres ahorita estamos
supremamente felices porque primero es
la antes la segunda en la consulta del
pacto histórico pero además les está
ganando a candidatos que ya han tenido
experiencias previas
en la contienda electoral como por
ejemplo sergio fajardo en la consulta
centro esperanza entonces eso además de
para las juventudes pero también para
las diversidades y para las mujeres es
un gran logro estamos realmente muy
felices que esta figura que desde
francia márquez esté tomando tanta
fuerza no sólo al interior del pacto
histórico sino ante todo lo que implica
el panorama político del país es muy muy
satisfactorio
muchas graciaslaura por tu tiempo
rodrigo te vuelvo la conexión al estudio